[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE FISHER: Hi, everyone.
I'm Mike Fisher.
I'm the CTO at Etsy.
Thanks for joining me today.
So I've been at
Etsy about a year.
Before that, I ran a
consultancy for about 10 years,
and one of my clients
happened to be Etsy.
So I've known them
for a very long time.
And I'm excited to share
the story about Etsy
and move into the
cloud with you today.
So Etsy is a global marketplace.
If you're not
familiar with us, we
have two million
creative entrepreneurs
that are connected to over
35 million active buyers
through 50 million unique
items that they make.
And these are artisans
and crafts people
who hand-make items or
collected vintage items
and sell them to the buyers.
We see ourselves
in a marketplace
as a force for good.
In the US, where only 40%
of entrepreneurs are women,
the creative entrepreneurs
at Etsy are over 87%.
Most of them work from
home because they're
artists and crafts people.
They turn their extra bedroom,
their kitchen table, the garage
into their studios
and workplaces
And our sellers are really the
hearts of Etsy and the products
that they make.
And I'm going to share with
you a quick video about one
of our sellers,
Dianne Nordt, who
I find very inspiring
about the care
and what she puts into
making Etsy's products.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BARKING]
[BAAING]
[END PLAYBACK]
MIKE FISHER: So
hopefully, that gave you
a sense of the type of
care that our sellers put
into their products and how
much that really means to them.
So that's what we find the
power of the marketplace
is to be able to enable
this creed of entrepreneurs.
But we not only see
the power that we
can do good for our sellers
but also for our own employees.
Again, in a world
where we only see
14% women engineers in the
industry, Etsy is a leader.
We see over 30% of our
engineers are women.
And if you increase that for
the entire technology team,
it's much higher than that.
Five out of eight of our
executive team are women.
And we have gender
parity across our Board.
And so not only do
we see ourselves
as a force for
good in the world,
but we also think that we can
do good for our employees.
Last fall, we announced our
mission of Keep Commerce Human.
And a lot of companies
try to use technology
to replace people.
But as Etsy, we see the
mission as using technology
to enable people to
connect with each other
and to augment that relationship
and their task that they do.
And whether that's connecting
a seller to a buyer,
and trying to
eliminate the currency
issues or the
communication issues,
or the shipping Issues
across the world,
or trying to empower an
employee to help fight fraud,
we see technology as augmenting
this instead of replacing.
And in a world of increasing
automation and commoditization,
creativity can't be automated.
And that human connection
really cannot be commoditized.
This is what drew me
to Etsy is the ability
to use two things
that I love, which
is helping support entrepreneurs
and applying technology.
And it's the combination
of those two things
that brought me to
Etsy and keep all
of us motivated each
day to continue working
for the sellers and buyers.
Now, Etsy engineers,
as I mentioned,
I've known them for
a number of years.
They've always had a really
strong engineering culture.
And we were very innovative
in the early years in some
of the areas like CI/CD.
So we were one of
the early places
that did continuous integration,
conduced employment.
DevOps, the concept of
monitoring everything--
all of these were
early, early concepts
that Etsy participated in.
And at that time, there
weren't a lot of tools.
And so they developed them.
The analogy would
be that if we're
building our house, that we
actually went out and cut down
the trees, and hand you the
logs, and made our own floors,
like the pioneers.
And when I came on
board a year ago,
one of the first tasks that our
CEO asked me to look at was,
should we be in some
of these areas again?
Should we be hand-building
our own monitoring stocks?
And one of the things that I
looked at first, because it
was such a big part
of our organization,
was the infrastructure.
So we were still
in data centers,
a lot of cases still
running on bare metal.
And so I took a look
at that and said,
is this really where we
should be concentrating
our engineering efforts
or are we in a world
now that we can leverage
a partner to do this with?
And so this started us down
the cloud path to look at--
can we find a vendor who
could partner with us,
and support us, and let
us concentrate on helping
the sellers and buyers?
And so continuing that analogy
of the house, we're in a world
now where you can hire an
architect and subcontractors
and stuff that build
that house for us.
And so this is what we
looked at the cloud journey
about a year ago and said,
let's start down that path
and let's figure out
who we can partner with.
Now, a lot of the things that
make Etsy unique and special
also make it incredibly
challenging from a technology
perspective.
So all of those 50 million items
are unique, handmade, creative.
We like to think of it sometimes
as the world's largest flash
sale, in that once
that item is sold,
there's often not
another item like it.
We also have unstructured data.
So we don't have a structured
listing, we don't have SKUs,
we don't have catalogs
and things like that
that a lot of our
products fall into,
that a typical e-commerce
company would have.
And so because of
that, it makes a lot
of things challenging
in terms of finding
that right item for those
buyers and to search
all 50 million items.
So lots of challenges.
And of course, we're
a global company.
We're in almost every
country in the world.
And so connecting the
sellers across that
to sell their products,
to communicate,
to transfer currencies, to ship
those products-- all of those
make our jobs really,
really challenging.
But that's what's fun about it.
One of the areas that is
specifically challenging
because of this data is search.
So in a typical search
algorithm that's using TF-IDF,
we look at the titles, the
tags, the descriptions,
things like that.
But the challenge is that those
sellers, like Dianne Nordt,
can describe the wool blankets
any way that she wants.
She can talk in her
description about the sheep
and how she raised them.
But someone else who's
making another wool blanket
might call it something
very different.
And so that makes it
really, really challenging
for a typical search-- you know,
solar index or something like
that--
to find the right results.
And so this is one
of the areas that we
found that we can apply machine
learning onto to provide
better results for the sellers.
And so enter something
that we call CSR, which
is Context Specific Ranking.
So Etsy generates
almost a billion,
over a billion events
a day for their buyers.
So the buyers are clicking,
they're looking at staff,
they favorite in,
they edit their cart,
they're purchasing things.
All of that data gets processed.
And we can use that in our
machine learning algorithms
to re-rank the search results
so that the results end up
being exactly what the
buyers are looking for
and not a combination
of everything
that's possible out there.
So this is an example of that.
On the left, you'll see
a typical search result
for alarm clocks, in this case.
But on Etsy, when you
search for alarm clocks,
you might be looking for
an actual alarm clock.
You also might be looking
for parts to an alarm clock
that you want to put in a piece
of art that you're making.
Or you might be looking for
stickers of alarm clocks.
You might be looking for prints.
There's no telling what
you are really looking for.
And so enter CSR--
on the right-hand side, where
we've taken all of the queries
that happened days
and days before
and looked at what the
users interacted with.
And we apply that back and
re-rank the search results.
And with that, we have something
that the user finds as a better
search result. And we see this
in the data of conversions,
the number of pages they have to
process through on their search
and all of this.
And all of that leads
us to show that it's
a better result for the buyers.
Another example
is wedding gowns.
On Etsy, you may be
looking for the material
to actually sew or
make your wedding gown.
You can also be looking for
bridesmaids' gifts, or wedding
gown hangers, or any
other number of items
when you search
for wedding gowns.
And so with CSR, we can
actually apply machine learning
on top of those search results
and produce a better result
for the buyer.
But all of this, as I
mentioned, takes a lot of data
and a lot of compute capacity.
In fact, that 1.2
billion results,
sometimes it can take almost
24 hours to process that data.
And if we train our algorithms
on more than a couple
of weeks worth of data, we
run into capacity issues.
And so if you're in
a traditional data
center, which we have
been, you know the cycle.
You have to plan a budget
months and months ahead of time.
And then you have
to order staff--
depending if you're doing
large orders-- maybe even
a number of months ahead.
And then you need to receive
it, you need to rack it,
you need to set it up.
And finally, you can actually
let the developers have access
to it.
And so this cycle is
really not conducive.
If you want to do fast
and really flexible
changes in the machine learning,
the data, the feature set,
the feature
engineering, all of that
that we want to have a
really high cycle time on
isn't very conducive.
But we also want to use
this in a sustainable way.
If we didn't "keep commerce
human" in everything we do--
meaning the way we do our
compute power to the way
that we consume food and
energy in our offices,
the way we heat and
cool our offices.
If we didn't do it
in a sustainable way,
it wouldn't be the way that
we're keeping commerce human.
And so sustainability is
a really big deal for us.
And so we've got
to look at not only
how do we get a lot more
compute capacity very flexibly,
but in a sustainable fashion.
So this graph in the upper
left is a typical sort
of e-commerce cycle.
Even though we're global, the US
is one of our largest markets.
And this is the typical cycle
of the early evening hours.
You know, traffic isn't
as great, it spikes up.
You see the dip when everyone
sort of travels home,
commutes home.
And then while they're
watching TV at night,
they're shopping on Etsy.
Over on the right is the
idle time of our web servers.
And it's about inverse of this.
So when the site
gets very busy, we
start to reduce the CPU idle.
When the site isn't so busy,
we get upwards of 90% idle.
Now, the interesting
thing is this
is our energy consumption
in our data center.
And you'll notice
that it's flat.
Because we don't have a virtual
environment where we can share
with someone else, we can't--
when we're not using it--
give it back.
We don't shut down the servers--
once they're in, they're in.
And so this isn't a
very sustainable way
to provide compute capacity
for the Marketplace.
And we care about
this so much, we
have publicly stated
our goals around having
ecological impact.
That we want a 100%
renewable energy
in the offices, and in the
data centers, and everything
that are on our compute by 2020.
And we want to reduce the
intensity of this by 25%
by 2025.
And the majority of
that is our compute.
It's taken up by
the data center.
And so that is a very big
goal of the engineering team,
that is to focus on that.
And of course, we have other
ecological impact goals
that we've announced.
And so enter the cloud.
The cloud allows
us the flexibility
to keep power that
we need, all of this,
to do it in a sustainable way.
And so that's what started us
on the journey to look at cloud.
The other thing is we mentioned
we're a global company.
And as you know, performance
matters on e-commerce sites,
on search engines, all of this.
What you see is page load times
across different countries.
We've highlighted a couple
here for Brazil and India.
And you'll see
that they spike up
and have really, really
terrible load times.
Google's own research
shows that just increasing
from one to three
seconds, and you get
a 32% increase in bounce rate.
And if you increase
it over 10 seconds,
you get 130-some
percent bounce rate.
And so this is really
important to us.
That when we're trying to
allow sellers and buyers
across the world to
connect to each other,
we have to have really
fast performance.
And having our data
centers located in the US
doesn't help us with this.
Even though we use CDNs
for our static content,
we have a lot of
dynamic content that we
need to generate in the
data centers or on site.
And so having a global presence
with a cloud provider really
is going to enable us to
improve our performance.
And so the decision
was made that we're
going to look for a
cloud provider partner.
But we really wanted one
that fit with our culture.
As I mentioned, Etsy has a
really strong engineering
culture.
And we wanted one that
we could partner with
and really believe that
they get our culture.
We wanted one that focused
on machine learning.
I describe the Marketplace
really as an iceberg.
And the Marketplace is
the tip of the iceberg.
And behind it,
what you don't see,
is all of those
billion events that
get processed every single day
in our big data infrastructure.
And then all of that
machine learning--
I mentioned one small
application of it,
but we're applying
it in lots of ways.
And we're going to keep
applying it more and more.
And so we wanted someone who
had a real focus on machine
learning.
We also wanted those
international data
centers so that we can
have points of presence
around the world.
And then, of course,
that strong commitment
to environmental
sustainability--
we wanted someone who really
understood what we meant
and how we felt about it,
and could partner with that.
So the question was,
well, how do you decide
who fits all of these criteria?
So we took one big project
of migrate to the cloud
and broke it down into a
bunch of smaller projects.
And we have-- even though
it's a single Marketplace--
we have hundreds of systems
within the Marketplace
and within the big data,
and the machine learning,
and all of these
that power that.
And so we broke that into
all of these subprojects.
We used a RACI model to
assign ownership of those.
And we asked those owners to
take that vision of that system
through an architectural review.
Some of these systems are
going to be imported, lifted
and shifted.
Some of them are going
to use new technologies.
Some of them are going to
be redesigned completely
to be cloud ready.
And so we wanted the
owners of these systems
to take that through the
architectural review process.
And what came out of that is a
set of requirements, thousands
of requirements from all of
these subprojects of what
they would need
going to the cloud
and out of the data center.
And so we took all of those and
used a tool called the decision
matrix.
We put all the requirements
into decision matrix.
And then we worked with
our cloud providers
to do experiments, and to do
lots of technical meetings
and architectural reviews with
the different cloud providers
to get their input on how
best to design and implement
our systems.
And this decision matrix
looks something like this.
Across the top, we have our
functional requirements.
These are the things
that are overarchingly
important to our business--
the relationship, the
cost, the ease of use,
the value-added services,
security, locations.
All of these are things that
are really, really important.
And they're kind of
overarching requirements.
And then down on
the left, you'll
see all of these
subproject requirements
that people came up with.
And there's literally thousands.
This is just a
screenshot of that.
And then we weighted them.
And we said, these
customer requirements,
how did they impact the
functional requirements?
And what we got out
of that was thousands
of customer requirements
that were weighted.
So we knew which ones were
the most important to us.
We then used these
weighted scores
to have the engineers rank
the different providers based
on that.
And so as they went through
their experimentation
or their discussions, they
could use the decision matrix
to rank them.
And they could say, this
provider fulfills those,
this provider doesn't.
At the end, we cross-multiply
everything out.
You have tens of
thousands of data points
that you can compare
these providers with.
And in our case, GCP
had over 50,000 points.
They won by over 10%.
And by using this
matrix, we tried
to eliminate people's bias.
And bias because they either
prefer one provider or another,
or they only had experience
with one provider or another.
And we tried to
eliminate all of that
and make this a very
quantifiable approach
that we felt good with,
that we knew that they
were going to support
our requirements
and meet our business needs.
And so we're moving
very, very quickly.
We announced the
partnership in December
that we are going to migrate
everything out of our data
centers to GCP.
We're on a two year timeline.
We almost immediately migrated
all of our image serving off
of Etsy into GCP.
And lots of the lots of other
subprojects-- the machine
learning, training,
infrastructure--
is now migrated to GCP.
And so lots of these
subprojects are already in step.
But we're planning on a
full two year migration
to get all of our
systems out of there.
Etsy Web is the big one.
And so we're trying
to break that down
to as many small
pieces as possible
to move the
Marketplace up to GCP.
And we, of course,
have to do this
around the busy times of year--
typical e-commerce company,
where we have lots of traffic
in the Q4, around holidays.
And so all of that has to
be taken into consideration
in timing of this.
But we already have all of
this running in the cloud.
And we're doing load
or performance testing
on that right now.
And so that's how we build
enough confidence is replaying
traffic against the
GCP infrastructure
with the Etsy Web
Marketplace running there.
And so all of that's going into
the migration step of this.
And so just to recap before
we take some questions,
we're a global marketplace.
We really, really believe in our
mission of Keep Commerce Human.
And that means everything
that we do has to follow that.
And that means not only our
engineering, but the way
we host, the way we build
our products, all of this.
We have a very strong
engineering culture.
And we wanted someone,
a partner that
could meet us there and
really fit within our culture.
We made the decision and
are doing the migration
by dividing it up into a
number of small projects,
utilizing that decision
matrix so that we
have a quantifiable decision
that we can feel good about
and stand behind that we
made the right decision.
And migrating to
GCP really allows
us to do this in a sustainable
fashion, that they really
get where we're coming from in
terms of having 100% renewable
energy and sustainably.
And really, we found,
I think, someone
that's proven to
be a great partner
in the migration with us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]